[Musique]
clap de fin pour le vaccinodromes de
saint quentin en yvelines après quatre
cent mille injections réalisées l'un des
centres les plus importants des yvelines
ferme ses portes un peu plus d'un an
après son ouverture il passe le relais à
la médecine de ville pour vacciner ses
habitants une convention a été signée
entre l'assurance-maladie des yvelines
et le resto du coeur dans le département
objectif de cette union permettra un
meilleur accès aux soins des
bénéficiaires 41 c'est le nombre de bus
de saint quentin en yvelines qui roulent
désormais au biométhane le dépôt de
trappes avait entamé en mai dernier sa
conversion au gaz naturel ces véhicules
en circulation constituent maintenant
une grande partie du réseau stibus le
conseil départemental des yvelines a
lancé son plan prévention car en ce
qu'on veut venir en aide aux communes
déficitaires de logements sociaux l'avic
du pec et la première en bénéficier avec
l'inauguration d'une résidence de 80 des
habitations une opération qui permet à
la commune de se rapprocher de
l'objectif des 25 % de logements sociaux
obligatoires fixé par l'état le cirque
que nicolas zavatta fini par faire
escale finalement sur l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 13
mars le maire de trappes refusé
d'installer le cirque dans la ville ils
ont finalement eu gain de cause par la
préfecture et puis enfin rama yade y
conserve son titre de championne wb à
continental elle a battu la championne
d'europe des poids légers lors du gala
de boxe organisé par le club dame
l'héritage au mur
[Musique]
pas